troisième défaite consécutive pour les
féminines de montigny le bretonneux dans
le championnat de national
une les vertes et loire se sont inclinés
dans les dernières secondes contre le
stade pessacais domicile le score 22 à
terrible déception effectivement car on
avait on avait préparé ce match on tombe
sur une équipe de pessac peut-être un
petit peu plus objective c'est à dire on
a beaucoup cherché des solutions
individuelles et dans des situations on
aurait dû jouer un petit peu plus
collectif contre le stress vous savez
les filles le stress vous savez quand
vous êtes à la dernière place
c'est un petit peu compliqué d'être
parfois de faire preuve d'objectivité
possible
le tournant du match la blessure de la
capitaine de montigny famille jean
baptiste en milieu de deuxième période
la blessure de fanni déjà nous fait mal
c'est vrai parce qu'on perd on perd pas
celle qui marqué le plus de buts c'est
notre capitaine
la famille est une joueuse qui est connu
comme do de la vidéo ils ont vu voilà
ils se sont coupés d'avant
malheureusement c'est un petit peu c'est
un petit peu dur pour nous après cette
défaite les hypothèses restent derrière
du classement à cinq journées de la fin
du championnat à un point du premier non
relégable l'aj auxerre graylois tant que
mathématiquement c'est possible on y
croit voilà on manque encore
d'expérience on est novice en est quand
même et on a fait quelque chose
aujourd'hui on sait quand même battu et
on a montré quelque chose et c'est même
ce qui est important c'est à la fin du
spectacle compagne les artistes comme on
dit par chez nous dans le midi là bas et
il reste encore des matches à jouer on
va les jouer vous pouvez compter sur
nous
prochain match pour les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux le samedi 16
avril sur le terrain 2 mai